for the first five minutes please
welcome fillip to the stage hi there
Thanks and somebody's Phillip night I'm
going to be doing a quick talk on why
the journalists one to learn Python the
way I was plan on doing that is talking
about an example of mine I'm a
journalist why did I want to learn a bit
Python since me I'm now a freelance
reporter up until january i was done
listed on an education trade magazine
that's kind of where I got my use case
for that I'm going to be talking about
basically something that a problem i had
our need ism data and i just couldn't
find a way to get good up to a day or so
I thought right I'm going to date myself
my use case quite love you probably know
what free schools are there a new type
of school that the government brought in
2010 the idea was introduced we now have
two hundred and fifty four of them and
the government is said that by the end
of this Parliament they're going to
introduce another 500 so small but
growing part of the school system and
one of the things as a journalist this
is actually a new interesting thing
wanna know how they're doing but most of
them have started with only one years
with the kids so it's going to be
several years until we get any exam
dates are out of them so question how
did you know how that forming it's the
best thing we really have is Ofsted
inspection software goes in within the
first couple of years of a school
opening and gives it one full ratings
one being out sounding down to four
inadequate if you're a fool bad things
start happening to you so my my issue
was I wanted to find out how all of
these free schools these open principles
were forming and there's no way of
really from the Ofsted website getting
data that's up to date on a group of
schools such as free schools they're
open so I wrote a bit of a Python
scraper this is the Ofsted website for
every school has its own one
been inspected gets its own age this is
the raisin here inspection date
publication date of the special report
the actual reports I haven't tried to
scrape because scraping pdfs is way
beyond me in a minute and this is what i
built so this is the site basically it's
a scraper hits the offset website every
morning 6am for every free school grabs
the results and then visualize is it a
bit of a bright n is different types of
school and then a big table with all the
results you can filter so you can check
their sorts check the latest results
that kind of thing so this gives us
information that would otherwise be
really hard to get we can see that about
75 Senate schools are outstanding or
good you've just got free release or
danger calgary how to do it the that if
anyone wants it is a URL link back end
is Python 2.7 so if you've written on
something called scraper wiki i don't
know how many of you come across it's a
code in your browser tool so if you're
you know you might actually need to use
it but it has some advantages far as I'm
concerned is paid for but it's free for
journalists which is quite nice you can
schedule it so you can run your scraper
say once a day 6am one of the robust
ones for me is that you can easily get a
JSON API endpoint for whatever data
you've grabbed which is basically what I
then use to produce my front end
libraries really nothing fancy requests
beautiful soup is a very common I think
the most commonly used scraping library
less capable key itself is also a
library that basically helps you save a
sequel
light database of your data from end
I've seen a couple of tourists wave of
mentioned d3 JavaScript library that if
you're going going with it is a very
good book but 80 from first principles
to being able to do some basic pie
charts that kind of thing uh that's if
you're interested please check out the
project my code is all from github an
MIT license and I've be interested to
hear any feedback any clothes on the
head other in person Twitter whatever um
I'll make that five minutes we times
thumbs up cool so yeah you might have
seen my talk on hacking human language
and this is about detecting stories in
books because I do work on books and
book summaries so yeah story detection
using lda and I'm just basically
building a tool to discover stories in
text and first foremost it's very hard
to define what constitutes a story and
how a story can be detected so as a
working definition I just use stories as
narratives on certain themes like a
friendship or habit and we can discuss
if this is an oversimplification it
surely is but it was useful for this so
the solution I came up with was
identifying stories by comparing text
chunks from a story to topic work
clusters unfortunately I didn't have to
do that myself there is a really cool
publication by yokas and me know where
they used the latent dirichlet
allocation lda to identify and extract
hundreds of topics from a corpus of 3346
works of 19th century british irish and
american fiction so this is lda and i
probably won't have enough time to go
really into detail but the nice thing
again we live in a Python world so we
can just use this LD a model in jensen
and what it does basically it comes up
with these topics so you have all these
clusters of words which are similar to
each other from the documents so from
these 3000
entire books and then actually the
researchers Yorkers and a me know they
went through it and labeled it because
that's very tedious so I had 500 label
clusters of themes from books so how did
I detect the stories i took my text i
sub divided it into chunks of 30
sentences and then for each word in a
text junk then the module was looping
through the available topics and looked
at words associated with that topic so
this is what came out when I put in the
book the power of habit and as you can
see a amusement while visiting places
which is rather obscure but you also
have things like friendship society
pleasure and so I did this for chunks
always 30 sentences each and you
actually have habit somewhere I don't
see it right now they are your habits
and customs you have duties task
employment and that was all I wanted to
show you thanks hello everybody my name
is Maria and I study mathematics at the
University of Warwick and i would like
to start with the squad just because
they like it and i think it's quite
suitable I Syria has Una's the
alternative of being cried of Ron a
model has a third opportunity it might
be right but irrelevant yes so what are
the reasons when it goes wrong there is
a very nice story it's a literature and
it's about a king who wanted to make a
map of his kingdom and he was keeping
asking his data scientists to make it
bigger and bigger and then at some point
the map just became as big as a kingdom
it represents and of course there was no
purpose of such a map and um when I
discuss the story of as different people
in mathematics are there is two types
first one say like okay but the kink is
right we want more details with Mort
more data we want to be as exact as
possible but the truth here is that we
have limited resources we have limited
memory and the truth is that this king
he didn't want anything he didn't got a
map he need to
because he was so strict about what he
want so sometimes it's really better try
from something simple I'm not saying
that that a complicated models are bad
no they're amazing but it it's always
good to try from something as simple as
possible and this is um and this is my
personal experience this is part of the
master Jesus have done and originally I
started to do something really amazing
critter complicated something nobody
ever done before but it didn't work in
two months it had nothing and then at
some point I just made this plot it took
me like 15 min 15 lines of Python code
and it tells me more than two monsters
I've done before yes so again i really
like when there is complicated models
but sometimes it's just better to start
from simple thought yeah so this is how
you might find me I'm graduating soon so
I'm open for opportunities one more
minute yeah I love item I have an art
degree and yeah that's all thank you all
all of us for inviting me here I wish
you all the best with your research and
this year job and I hope to see you in
by meetups hi I'm Gemma and I'm a
developer it's been one hour 47 minutes
and 13 seconds since I touched a line of
code I spent seven months working on a
hair care website and of those 140 or so
days I enjoyed give or take about three
of them and those those days were the
days i got to optimize things what
divides my kid and i'm here to talk
about why i love i love doing that and
why you should care about it i literally
i feel like you probably don't need to
be told is butts
acacia does need to be said I usually
work for agencies on short timescales
we're getting something to work is all
that matters there isn't necessary
there's no there's no business
requirement in getting it to work even
faster but even more efficiently but
programming isn't just a job for me and
joy I love it but it is fundamentally
it's a craft me the it's the knowledge
of problem-solving lizil it always
changes i enjoyed but fundamentally when
I buildings I want a bill Salus
efficient that's beautiful and well
engineered prepare but part of my brain
that writes code is the same bit of my
brain that writes pros there's a flow
there's a rhythm that there's a weave
and a weft to it when it takes
something's the work slowly and make it
lightning fast it's not only an
enjoyable challenge it's the pinnacle of
my skill I don't feel like I'm a curb
monkey mashing buttons anymore I feel
like I'm actually an engineer at that
point it's something I love doing when I
was writing his talk I came up with a
few ideas with some problems i was
working on and i had to close them
closer to close my editor is a bright
talk first optimize later unless you're
living right in the event horizon of a
black hole times kind of important to
you and even then still very slow down
time but it doesn't matter whether
you're caring about the response time on
a website or whether you're doing deep
learning time is directly was
proportionate to your AWS bill so I'd
like to introduce you to my latest
obsession rescuing bill kerman I don't
know if any of you've had I've got lost
on kerbal space program this is them
this is my minecraft come back during my
original experimentations I left poor
bill up actually if you look at the
orbit he's really close to home but he's
never getting home because I kind of ran
out of fuel
so I decided they have my space plane
was going to vote itself to rescuing him
my first attempt was look at the
original craft built in all the
redundancies add lots of extra power
because there are all the possibilities
and I got the thing that worked there's
one slight problem here when if anybody
else has orbital mechanics you'll
understand that when I launch this thing
and it left the earth-moon system
without using any orbital engineering or
any orbital read it redirecting I may
have made it a little bit too powerful
so I went back to what am I originally
trying to do the problem is when I was
designing the original craft it needed a
little backup engine that could
decelerate out of orbit so I started
working on a basic probe automated
systems very lightweight and all this
going to do is go but extra fuel take a
little walk it on the front end on the
on the front end if you look at sort of
the scale this is the what actually
brought bill home so what I'd like to
now show talk to you through is my three
top tips for optimizing your code first
one don't optimize your code the listen
I keep coming across and it's on the
occasion I still do myself is I current
has pro people who are trying to have
stuck trying to solve problems and
optimize all the first step what matters
in with your first iteration of your
code should be should be the that it
works doesn't matter how fast it is
doesn't know how elegant it is it get it
to work first and then optimize it now
as you get better you'll naturally make
things more as you get better you will
naturally make things more optimized
what I writing the first draft now is
far more optimized than what my final
product 5-10 years ago second step be
evil always stress test what you're
doing what's a bill
ok build-a-lot zoo build a large data
set throw at it so nothing is so the
love stage set throw it at it even if
its larger than what you're expecting
the moment it'll break it will show you
any to focus on final thing breaking
Santa is it individual components as
possible and then you'll be able to
focus on the right areas which
subjugates back to prep on video this is
be in program tool and click yes so
start a timer there we go so am i was
listening to all these different amazing
talks we're having here in in London
well one thing kind of reminded me of my
actual education in social science so I
want confession to make I'm not really a
data scientist by profession I'm
actually trained as a social sciences
and anthropologist and as an
anthropologist I like to ask things
about culture and about all these kind
of aspects and language so from that
perspective let me just show you some of
the things which in anthropology or
considered really important and mostly
true crisises which have accurate I want
to actually share my ideas about these
things how they might also apply to data
science well switching over to you know
from the from soda sizemore two
fundamental real science as we might
call it I was actually amazed by the
lack of philosophy and the lack of
ethics and the lack of kind of moral
argumentation about what we are actually
doing as data scientists in society so
therefore I would like to just go a
little bit about ethics so ethics is the
branch of philosophy that deals with the
distinctions between right and wrong and
with a moral consciousness of human
action and basically if that's what we
accepted the fact we can also say that
data ethics would be the moral
responsibility influencing any of our
activities and practices as data
scientists so what does that mean we all
know the Hippocratic oath for medical
science it's not really legally binding
in any sense anymore but it used to be I
think here you could be killed or shot
or whatever if you would break it as a
medical specialist in ancient Rome I
will prescribe regimen for the good of
my patients according to my ability and
judgment and never do no harm to anyone
and of course you can't really compare
medical science to to data science it's
very different things from you know what
you're doing for clients or on the web
from you know helping treatments or
where you maybe might be able to kill
people but at the same time and
especially my discipline is deep
learning where we all know we're all
afraid of Skynet and maybe things taking
over our jobs and things like this I
think it's really important to question
these things and things about what might
be actually the consequences of our
actions which we're doing and as an
anthropologist I was always slapped
around by my professors with AAA code of
context so the American Association
called conduct with basically in short
just as you know do no evil Google style
but how this came to be is actually
quite interesting there was no such
called contact until there was this big
big big crisis story darkness and
although that is one of the books which
describes it quite well which was about
an anthropologist team who were studying
an Asian tribal folk call to Yanam
animal and they kind of misbehaved there
they all represented certain things they
had some sexual intercourse was maybe
not really considered nice they didn't
really inform the Yanomami people about
what they were doing there or there was
no like code of conduct or ethical
concerns about these things and there's
all this kind of other stories about
that they might have also committed some
unattended genocide by introducing all
kinds from some different kinds of Vox
ends with them turned out not to be
actually really true but it anyway
sparked a debate and that's how they a
code of conduct was born so for data
science we also have seen some of these
things happening a larger smaller extent
we have facebook facing criticism for
its its study where they basically
changed for half of their study group
they changed the timeline to showing
only a little bit more positive news and
the other half showing a little bit more
negative news but of course people were
not informed of this that they were part
of an experiment and rightly so I would
say they were very much criticized for
that but they're sort of things also
happening with with data and with the
systems we built that of course
subscribe to some of this which is more
about privacy and things does this prism
yes we scan etc so having all of these
things in mind I think we do have some
ethical concerns and we should really be
able to think about these things so the
question then is do we need a
Hippocratic oath for data science with
basic means how do we explain to society
what we are doing is like the scientist
or or computer scientists however you
want to subscribe resolve or data miners
algorithms don't speak you know
algorithm is also have to be explained
by itself that there is an algorithm
that it can do right or Rome it still
means is that where are you know our our
concerns and should we take it further
than that and also who owns which data
if there is a data set does that mean
that it's available that you can always
use it or do people have to say
something about it from always in the
date of them that's all I wanted to say
and something I did forget to mention
for my dog on the blurring if you ever
round find yourself in the windy
Stockholm come do come around for the
circum deep learning meet up that's it
right so yesterday Russell winder was
giving a talk around basically looking
at why poynton isn't ideal for doing a
high number crunching stuff really kind
of intense computational stuff and it
made me well there was all the talk made
me feel a little bit angry really
because and I couldn't quite figure out
why I felt angry about it all kind of
frustrated by the message the what he
was doing was he was trying to calculate
pi using an algorithm and he kind of
showed that the Python isn't fast enough
to do this and you need to look at other
languages like C++ and D so I kind of I
well I really wanted to prove him wrong
because i really like pipes in his
language but I wasn't quite sure why he
was one right so this is this talk is
basically about me kind of investigating
why
but I feel he was one okay so i can
scroll so one of the first things I did
right was I decided I White Sea
extension to implement the code that
Russell was using in these benchmarks
because they're nice and simple or you
know so I was thinking so this is the
kind of code you need to write here in
this blog here this is the kind of code
you need to write to implement a see
extension this is a Russell's algorithm
it does some stuff like it releases the
gill so that you should be able to run
it multi-threaded I've broken is eigen
and down so you can run you can run
multiple bits of it in separate threads
the idea that would be that you've then
wrapped it in a some Python code that
would spawn multiple threads and
splitters algorithm of multiple threads
right this is just all the plate for
registering on module the after actually
doing this and finding out you know so
initially I was thinking this is really
simple it'll be easy to prove Russell
wrong it turns out actually it was much
more difficult to write to see module
than I remembered I spent a lot of time
looking at the docks I spent a lot of
time debugging it um I broke things in
really bizarre ways that I wasn't
expecting just by deleting lines and
bizarre things happening it's still much
faster than than implementing the same
algorithm in Titan but it's it's just
not excitingly fast right it's still
quite boring right it takes two seconds
to calculate pi right and I want pie
much faster than that so but the next
kind of bit of thought I had was well
you know kind of my my little Chromebook
here which is what I was running it on
only has two cores and they're quite
weak cause right so this is a CPU bound
algorithm so what I need is more cpus
right so I'll just go to the cloud and
I'll get loads of CPUs but the and I
price and notebook would make that
really simple because it has built in
distributed computing support it could
be quite easy but there's also quite a
lot of negatives with that kind of thing
it's it's a lot more costly it would
require some kind of cluster management
code and even then i'd still have a at
least network latency as a problem so it
still took me maybe 100 milliseconds or
so to get a value for pi which just
seems too long
so that then led me to think well maybe
someones count fact figured out a better
way of calculating pi surely someone's
calculated PI before right so the result
of that was me finding very quickly some
code on the stack overflow that
purported to calculate pi and so I
turned that into this is basically the
code I found on stack overflow I turned
it into an infinite generator four
digits of pi so this thing will just
yield you know 31 whatever the other
digits of pi r and there we go so here
it's using some it's a tool stuff so I'm
generating two thousand characters from
PI is a string and then to make it kind
of something nice that I might actually
want to use in Python i'm using the
decimal knoblich module it's built into
Python and I'm creating a way by which
you can get a decimal which is like it's
a high-precision like a kind of fixed
point representation of numbers so I'm
creating a way to construct that and I
use like the the decimals context and
stuff to decide the precision or you can
tell how many digits you want that kind
of thing so result of that is that we
can generate PI to a load of different
numbers of significant figures and it's
fairly fast so muscles example took well
over two seconds for Python
implementation this one takes half a
millisecond to generate 29 significant
figures and you know a few milliseconds
to generate 200 so what what did I
really conclude from this right exists
is a pretty silly weird thing to be
doing right um the micro benchmark which
was obviously a kind of silly contrived
example all right what was it that I
felt was wrong with it right I didn't
feel like this is ever the kind of
problem might come across okay right
okay so conclusions right so I don't
think that this is really a problem with
bison points that makes it
really easy for you to write good
algorithms of this to be in them so I
don't really feel that we have that kind
of problem because it's really easy to
disagree better algorithms so I
basically better algorithms is my
conclusion okay so this is going to be a
very quick talk about going to Mars with
Python in five minutes okay so Warren
this is a rocket science talk okay this
is gonna be well interesting with lots
of rockets and photos of spacecraft and
everything so what is astrodynamics in
the first place astrodynamics orbital
mechanics is a branch of mechanics which
studies practical problems concerning
the motion of rockets and spacecraft
through space for example this is the
plot of the receiver journey mission
which is the mission that we used to put
a probe on a comet for the first time in
human history and you can see there that
the trajectory was quite involved
because he had to go through the innards
and then earth and the earth again and
in general Drina a tree that was like 10
years long so what is polyester the pure
python library for us to dynamics which
is my personal project what I'm going to
talk about right now I also love kerbal
space program by the way so let's go to
Mars these are some initial import that
I have to make this 100 polyester
modules the last one is we are
downloading a file from the NASA the
NASA the JPL website which will tell us
the position and the velocities of the
planet so first thing we have to do is
defining the orbit we basically knew we
basically need three things the
attractor in this case the earth the
position and the velocity vectors and we
do this code and we have a nice plot of
orbit second we have to locate the
planets using the NASA fine that I told
you before we have we can provide a date
in time and then we'll treat the
position vector and the velocity vector
okay there's a bag over that I still
have to fix but it kind of works so far
the third thing we have to compute the
trajectory so this algorithm called the
Lambert problem that I implemented so
basically we give the initial time the
arrival time and it calculates the two
velocities I need to develop to go from
one side to the other
ah by the way this is implemented in
pure python as you can see there that
line was the previous implementation in
fortran in blue the pure python
implementation in red at the number
implementation sorry in blue and the
fortune in green so when I saw this I
said okay just throw away all the
fortune code and get on with it so forth
let's go to Mars this is a lot of
boilerplate code to get all the
parameters working and all the plotting
stuff so nothing interesting and there
you have it we went to much this is
actually the plot of the mass scientific
laboratory which is the Curiosity rover
and well there's still one thing that I
can do which is making it interactive if
you went to my talk before about ipython
notebook you already know that I am in
love with it but oh no no I have to
begin from the start okay don't worry no
panic oh man do we have x 2 yes please
run all yes it's true drive well come on
come on come on come on don't make us
wait sup mats please what is it
okay okay like the most sometimes work
all right so they are having a game
tomorrow click click click click click
go to Mars go too much interactively
okay so I have two parameters the data
plans and the time of flight so if I
change in advance the time of lounge
that you will see that the earth is
moving forward in time again in its
orbit and if I also change the time that
I want the spacecraft to travel for
example this way ah then I get a shorter
or a longer or it in this way okay so
that's pretty much all about it I
finally made it and thank you very much
ready go wait hi I'm David McKeever I'm
here to talk to you about my testing
library hypothesis protection has
nothing to do with I thought this
testing I'm really sorry about the name
so what is it actually that it's a
randomized testing library and what it
does is that instead of in your tests
writing examples yourself you say
roughly what shape of examples you want
to try your code against and it then
generates a whole bunch of examples of
that shape and if any of them throw your
test then your test is still is failing
and it gives you a nice little example
to demonstrate problem we are going to
look at it on a problem that your
program encounter before I only use it
because it's 1 i'm quite familiar with
is called feedback our temper
tournaments and it is a ranking problem
you have a matrix that says of these
coordinates which order they shun should
they go in and if everything we're
Knights intransitive this would just a
simple sort but it's not and actually
this is a super NP hard problem it's
basically for people who found traveling
salesman too easy and want something a
bit more of a challenge so N equals 30
you can do n equals 100 you can't unless
you're really lucky here is a really bad
implementation the top is our cost
function and the bottom is the heuristic
sorting algorithm we're going to be
using and what we've done here is we've
given every index a numeric wait we're a
higher weight means they're a bunch of
other numbers we've been told me to sort
before this and so a higher way it
should indicate this should go towards
the end
and we just add up the numbers we have
to give this right answer so this is bad
you should never use this implementation
but it might be a good heuristic
starting point and let's use hypothesis
to show us that it's bad and this is
what the test is look like this is all
and what we're doing here is we're
saying okay this is supposed to be a
global optimum so at the very least it
must be a local optimum and in order to
be a local optimum under any sort of
transformations the one we're going to
go with is we should never get it
backwards we should never find ourselves
in a position where if we just reverse
the order of the optimizer gave us we
actually get a better result that's
probably a bad sign so we say to
hypothesis can you give me three by
three arrays on side ventures which
we're going to use as our waiting
tournament for the scores it could be
much larger than three by three I pic 3
by 3 because I need the examples to fit
on a slide that's the only reason and
other than that that's pretty much it we
have our test function it's Rutten it
runs against the tournament were given
and we do the cost of both the forward
and the reverse result so we run this
under pie test it can run or anything
but I like pie test and it says know
your code is broken and this is the
example that hypothesis given us is this
lovely little matrix of zeros and ones
honesty compels me to admit it's usually
not that nice we got that we got
slightly lucky here but it's usually
quite nice because hypothesis has good
quality simplification of examples as
well as random generation and what has
happened here is you see all the columns
add up to one and what that means is
that here is we've got the same turistic
wait for everything and so the sort was
basically useless but actually there was
something interesting going on its
matrix and we wanted to put two before
zero so the reverse was better in this
case and the printing is mostly pie test
output and that's pretty much it for the
appropriate for using hypothesis you can
use this you know we benefited from the
fact that our implementation was really
bad so it's very easy to write a test
for this but you can use much the same
technique for much better
implementations you can set a curb the
output and assert that that doesn't
prove the result you can start from
other coins you can run a local
optimization procedure you can
anything like this for testing an
optimizer and you can use it for other
things as well but this was just a good
example for using be numb by support and
that is more or less all I have to say
on the subject so let's have a quick
conclusion so hypothesis is hooking up
your examples to high quality random
data so you don't have to write examples
yourself you can focus on testing and
the invariance your code which is the
interesting bit and the important bit
and you don't have to spend a lot of
time on other parts of the process and
it will probably do a better job than
you would have anyway most people find
that bothers finds interesting bugs in
their code the first time they run it so
basically you should be using about
statistic owed because it is great and
it will save you time and it will
improve the quality of your software and
that's pretty much all that allowed to
say here are some links the top is me
david McKeever the middle is the
hypothesis documentation and finally
here is a link to these slides if you
want to take a look at the examples
again I'll also tweet these on the
hashtag that's it okay fine name's Carol
from Fort Lee canadian-based company for
Montreal start-up just been going now
just over what 18 months 18 months one
good me to do tainted a quick overview
plot Lee very quick followed by using
ipython notebook widgets okay one of the
things I wanted to get over is this the
last couple of days another seminars
have been meeting lots and lots of
people they've all got this idea portly
runs on an SV cloud and you've got
limited files and my data should be kept
very very secure within my company we do
have an enterprise edition which runs on
a secure linux server on your company
premises something like quad core i5 or
i7 we'll run it so it does stay behind
your fault firewall so please don't
think of us as on online only we do we
do run on your servers as well okay so
what we do we've got api's python
app are no Jas Julia and Excel for
inputting data we do look at a configure
converters matplotlib ggplot etc why
bother I of I hear you ask and the
reason is because we convert your
figures into beautiful online shareable
pluckley graphs which are ready ready
for publishing of that's online or in on
paper format right how do we go about it
for example I've got some code here it's
when within a spider bites anaconda
Python interpreter you run the code it
automatically pulls up properly and it
opens up Oh to automatically showing the
plot if we go through from here we can
see we also get the data we also get the
code but if you look at the right hand
side we've also got we can also
communicate with people that are
programming with matlab javascript r and
Julia we can also keep all the original
data together which means that never
gets lost and we also have version
control as well what else can we do we
can for can edit we can share we can
edit traces we can have multiple axes we
can add labels we can drill down using
d3 so we can drill in and out of off the
of the graph we can also collaborate and
embed graphs as well if you look here we
can add a collaborator it's a bit like
Google Doc google for graphs or rather
than doing online and we can also if you
see on the right hand side of the middle
we've got in bed so we can go straight
from portly and in bed into into a
website other things we do you can
collect data arduino is one example
where we can get streaming data so if
you are measuring things like
temperature or basic senses
we can cope with that okay so the next
thing I'm going to do I'm going to end
this and I'm going to go and show you
where our widgets are okay so this is
using ipython notebook which has got the
the widget functionality with this we're
running it with a plot Glee 3d graph why
bother the reason being is that you can
drill in and you can drill out of your
data you can look at certain parts of it
which might be of interest this one's a
3d one I shall show you another one this
is i'm using pandas here and you might
say well what can we use there but it's
running here you can see it's actually
sorting i just want to have a look at
the taxis now maybe the next one is
going to be a tree week having look at
trees within the chart so you can see
again now we're looking at taxis again
so you can choose what areas of the
graphical you want to look at this again
ipython notebook using pandas and my
very last one i'm going to show you is
this because very soon we have maps
coming from properly that you can see
here we can go over the topography of
the map and we can actually see the
proper pantel so again that's you
slicing widgets use an eye python a
notebook with clock lee so thank you
very much indeed for listening to me